lassen Sie uns doch heute mit einer
kleinen Bibelstunde beginnen und mit
einem Zitat aus der Bibel es ist in
keinem anderen heil denn in dem Namen
Jesu zur Ehre Gottes des Vaters das in
dem Namen Jesu sich beugen sollen aller
derer Knie die im Himmel und auf Erden
und unter der Erde sind er diesen Satz
diesen Text an der Kuppel ist nachgebaut
Berliner Stadtschlosses möchte grünen
Politikerin Claudia Roth nun
vorübergehend überblenden der Grund die
Kulturbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
hält den Bibeltext für nicht weltoffen
und unangemessen ich als Gläubige
evangelin muss sagen dass ich das sehr
schwierig finde auch für mich persönlich
diese Einstellung zur Kirche Herr
dorundoff überspitzt formuliert ist denn
der christliche Glaube unangemessen
natürlich nicht also gerade hier in
Deutschland ist er ja geprägt durch die
christlichen Glauben wir sind ja auch
sehr tolerant wir wissen ja dass wir in
einigen Moscheen und auch in Köln ja
sehr tolerant sind in Köln ruft jetzt
auch der muizin genau also man kann uns
nicht vorwerfen dass dass wir nicht
tolerant sind aber wir müssen es auch zu
unserer eigenen Kirche und zwar unserem
eigenen Land natürlich
bekunden und das halt wichtig und
insofern kann ich das überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen was Frau Rother gerade
macht aber das wieder typisch zu den
Grünen aber da kommen wir nachher noch
mal drauf ist sie denn für Sie generell
eine gute nein Frau nein also sie ist ja
sehr
schrill und das mal so auszudrücken bin
ich auch das können wir nicht als
Beleidigung Geld lassen oder keine
Beleidigung sein aber das ist halt der
Unterschied und alles in dem Bereich was
die da bringt ist halt nicht mein Thema
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen und es ist
halt einfach schwierig ja man ist
tolerant aber so wie sie es jetzt auch
gerade macht dass man es abhängen soll
das ist unglaublich
Frau Gaschke also es ist ja schon
merkwürdig dass das jetzt überblendet
werden soll aber wie Herr dohrendorf
auch gerade angesprochen hat in Köln der
Munition Ruf wie sehen Sie denn die
Entwicklung von Frau Roth ich finde das
auch unsinnig also nun hat man sich das
war ja sehr umstritten und hat man sich
entschlossen das Stadtschloss
historisierend wieder aufzubauen es gab
viele Leute die das lieber anders
gemacht hätten also was weiß ich eine
eingekapselt ein eingekapselten Palast
der Republik oder irgendwas wäre auch
eine interessante Variante gewesen hat
man also das historische genommen und
die historische Inschrift die dahin
gehört die darf da jetzt nicht stehen
das passt für mich in so einem großen
Zusammenhang es wird ja in vielen
Städten gemacht also bis hin dazu dass
man die Erich kästner-straße umbenennen
will das Hindenburgufer in meiner
Heimatstadt Kiel darf nur noch Kiellinie
heißen und ich glaube viele Linke haben
immer die Hoffnung dass die Geschichte
dadurch irgendwie besser wird dass man
Sachen umbenennt oder zudeckt und das
ist natürlich Unsinn die Geschichte
bleibt ganz genauso ich würde sagen es
gibt Fälle wo definitiv Erläuterungen
nötig sind das kann man ja immer machen
gerade in die Tafel dazu machen wobei
man jetzt die Frage also ob man einen
Bibelzitat erläutern muss es ist ja
durchaus menschenfreundlich also es ist
ja nichts Böses sozusagen insofern hier
kann ich es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
verstehen und sie möchte es ja
vorübergehend während einer Ausstellung
also in der Kunstausstellung auch
verblenden da habe ich mich halt auch
gefragt ob wir nicht als weltoffen
gelten als Deutschland wegen einem
Bibelzitat das ist ja schon eine
merkwürdige Denkweise kann man sagen
dass generell die Grünen etwas gegen die
Kirche haben das glaube ich eigentlich
nicht wenn sie sich mal die evangelische
Synode ansehen oder so da ist durchaus
grün geprägt also sowohl vom Auftreten
als auch von den Themen her also gibt es
durchaus eine Affinität und sozusagen
dieses grüne hat ja häufig auch etwas
protestantisch freudloses also
etwas anstrengende Weise also ich bin
Protestantin und sehr freudig immer
unterwegs aber das gibt es das gibt es
auch aber es gibt eben auch das ist
etwas calvinistische oder also ja also
insofern ich ich kann es nicht ganz
verstehen ich glaube dass das
Spannungsverhältnis wäre doch viel ich
weiß jetzt gar nicht in welcher
Ausstellung es geht aber wenn es da
entspannungsverhältnis geben sollte ist
doch viel interessanter das auszuhalten
und zu diskutieren
ich verstehe ganz viele Dinge nicht ich
bin ja datenanalyst und bei mir sind
immer sehr viele Grundlagen um eine
Abwägung zu machen um Abwägungsprozess
überhaupt einzuleiten ich kann den hier
gar nicht erkennen ich kann einfach nur
sehen dass hier aus einer bestimmten
Weltsicht heraus bestimmte Dinge gemacht
worden sind die werden einfach
durchgeführt und es wird nicht mit
irgendwem besprochen in einer großen in
einem großen Umfeld es wird einfach
gemacht und meines Erachtens haben wir
uns tatsächlich die neue Regierung
gewählt als eine Regierung der
kindlichen Weltsicht wir sehen das ja an
vielen verschiedenen Aspekten ich finde
dieser ist eigentlich ein gutes Beispiel
man macht sich die Welt wie man sie
gerne hätte und wie sie einem gefällt
und so findet das auch hier statt
kindische weltsichtung kindliche Welt
sich was verstehen Sie darunter darunter
verstehe ich Dinge die einfach so in den
Raum gerufen werden ohne eine fundierte
Grundlage zu haben und ohne zu wissen wo
das alles endet einfach mal etwas
umzukrempeln so macht man das ja auch an
der Sandkiste haben Sie das Gefühl dass
wir unsere Kultur auch ein Stück weit
aufgeben
wegschieben wollen also insgesamt ist ja
die Frage jede jedes zusammenlebende
menschengeflecht ist ja zunächst einmal
grundsätzlich auf einem Gebiet in dem es
eine eigene Sprache spricht und solange
es eine eigene Sprache spricht gibt es
auch immer Abgrenzungen zu anderen
menschengeflechten die eine andere
Sprache sprechen so das heißt also in
diesem Raum finden eigenständige Dinge
statt und diese eigenständigen Dinge
werden jetzt quasi
geändert und man experimentiert auf eine
gewisse Art und Weise ob die Änderungen
auch funktionieren oder nicht das weiß
man nicht und man hat auch gar keine
Prognosen dafür sondern man sagt einfach
man möchte das gerne und das ist für
mich eine Art von kindlicher
weltgestaltung und ob das gut ist oder
nicht wir haben das gewählt
offensichtlich ist in Deutschland ein
gewisser Spaß daran ein gewisses
Vergnügen daran wie kindliche Weltsicht
von einer kindlichen Welt sich regiert
zu werden
sie sind keine Politikwissenschaftler
kein Religionswissenschaftler aber
trotzdem die Frage an Sie auch geben wir
ein Stück unserer Kultur auf wie
empfinden Sie das als Bürger
sehr eindeutig ich finde das Religion
nicht in die Öffentlichkeit gehört
sondern etwas sehr privates ist und sich
darüber aufzuregen wir haben genug
Glaubenskriege im Leben geführt fände
ich einfach viel besser wenn man das aus
diesem ganzen Diskussionen raushält und
vor allen Dingen dabei kann
missionarischen Eifer entwickelt sie
verstehen die Frau Roth dass sie das
überblenden möchte das Bibel versteht
als in ihrer Aufgabe eine Meinung haben
sollte ja ob das dann richtig ist oder
falsch ist sie noch immer unsere Sache
darüber nachzudenken aber eine zeitweise
Verblendung ändert ja nicht unsere
Kultur deswegen ich finde es einfach man
sollte überlegen was möchte sie damit
erreichen warum macht sie das es gibt ja
bestimmte Begründungen für viele Sachen
und da kann man sich ja anschließen und
nicht anschließen aber muss es ja nicht
mit in irgendwelchen Konfrontation
schwarz-weiß machen man kann es ja auch
wirklich mal versuchen zu verstehen
warum sie vielleicht
Aussicht in Ansicht ist und ich würde
gerade beim Kreieren sagen das ist eine
Privatangelegenheit und sollte auch so
behandelt werden wenn es um öffentliche
Themen geht ja aber ich meine
Entschuldigung also Sie können ja gerne
eine andere Meinung haben ja klar es ist
ja ein bisschen schwierig also Religion
nicht in der Öffentlichkeit also wir
haben ja auch überall Kirchen rumstehen
die sozusagen mit mit Kreuz auf dem Turm
Bayern sind kreuzen Glocken einfach
sozusagen ja den den christlichen
Glauben sozusagen als Gebäude darstellen
nicht evangelischen katholisch wie
vorher weil wir haben nur einen Himmel
und wir haben auch nur einen Glauben im
Prinzip dass uns zwischendurch da
getrennt haben finde ich immer noch
schade weil der christliche Glauben hat
den gleichen Ursprung und wir haben gibt
aber schon Unterschiede also ich bin
wirklich Gläubiger Evangelien und ich
muss sagen es gibt schon Unterschiede
zwischen katholisch und evangelisch ich
war ganz große Unterschiede ich bin
Kölsch katholisch was besondere Form ist
und ich habe lange in der ökumenischen
Beziehung gelebt deswegen ich kenne
beide Kirchen und auch von ihren
Vorständen und so weiter her sagen ja es
wäre schöner wenn wir zusammen werden ja
nur vielleicht einfach noch mal also was
was ich tatsächlich bei Frau Roth eben
nicht gut verstehen kann ist also nun
leben wir ja mal damit dass also der
Bundestag in seiner Weisheit beschlossen
hat also das war eine Bund Länder
Entscheidung wenn ich mir recht erinnere
sozusagen dieses Schloss in dieser Form
wieder aufzubauen das kann man aus
vielen Gründen ja auch ziemlich
merkwürdig finden also soll man
überhaupt historische Gebäude dann
wieder so nachbauen oder ist das im
Grunde so eine Disneyland Veranstaltung
dann also hätte man diesen Platz da
nicht auch anders gestalten können hätte
man sich mit der DDR Geschichte nicht
tatsächlich irgendwie auseinandersetzen
können jetzt mal abgesehen vom Asbest im
Palast der Republik wenn man das aber
tut dann sozusagen ein Teil der
historischen Wahrheit nämlich dass man
sich zu der Zeit auf diese Art von
Christentum berufen hat und das eben
öffentlich einfach auszulassen oder
abzuhängen das verstehe ich
intellektuell tatsächlich nicht so
richtig was das soll wie wie gefährlich
ist das denn ich erkläre das nicht ich
kann es nur wahrnehmen dass es nicht das
Christentum gibt sondern verschiedene
Glaubensrichtungen dabei und das da auch
verschiedene Meinungen
Öffentlichkeit
das schon ja auch in Köln ja aber es ist
ein wohlziehen und die waren wie viele
Kirchen ja also ich finde dass wir die
Multikulti-Gesellschaft durchaus auch
abbilden können und jedem der zu uns
gekommen ist und bei uns lebt auch sein
Zuhause geben kann ja und sich zu Hause
zu fühlen wir müssen doch nicht
konfrontativ damit umgehen dass es die
der Dicke bitte in Köln am lautesten
läutet ist ja immer noch so ich versuche
das zu verstehen also Bibelvers nein
beziehungsweise bei Blendung in Ordnung
Verblendung in Ordnung aber muizine ruft
ja das heißt sie sind für religiöse
Symbole oder Tätigkeit in der
Öffentlichkeit aber nicht für alle
ich bin für religiöse Symbole in der
Öffentlichkeit wenn es die Religion
betrifft und den Menschen persönlich ja
aber ich bin eigentlich gegen
konfrontatives auseinandersetzen gerade
eine Meinung durchzusetzen wir haben ja
doch gelernt mittlerweile friedlicher
zusammenzuleben und müssen uns dann noch
nicht gegenseitig Zank über irgendwas
was wirklich keine weh tut man kann den
Spruch von unten überhaupt nicht lesen
man muss ihn schon abgebildet sehen um
überhaupt zu sehen was da oben steht er
denn dann Frau Roth genau das ist ja
wenn sie sagen ja genau aber ich meine
nur warum sollte er dann die gestellt
oder nicht überhaupt stören okay ja aber
da können ja durchaus verschiedene
Meinungen sein absolut dafür treffen wir
uns hier ja immer dienstags
wie hat sie denn das verhüllt wie sieht
denn das überhaupt
auseinander
es ist noch nicht verhüllt worden sie
will es verhüllen mit einem Tuch oder
mit etwas drüber es ist ja noch nicht
verhüllt das ist ja auch gerade erst
wieder aufgebaut der Stadt Schloss okay
und dementsprechend werden wir jetzt mal
gucken wie es in der Zukunft weitergeht